welcome all of you and thank you all
very much for joining us can I put the
first question and can I ask each of you
how helpful you think that the cost of
living support payments have been and
the arrangements for them have been for
the people that your organization works
with starting with Helen Barnard
um so I think if you look at last year
if you look at it overall we saw the
highest need ever for food banks so we
gave out three million three Parcels
that was a 37 increase on the year
before more than a million for children
for the first time so if you look at it
overall even with every bit of support
that was put in we were still seeing a
lot of people in really dire hardship
when you then look in our data at what
happens every time each cost of living
payment comes in what you can see really
clearly is they did definitely help so
when the first one came in in July we
saw a dip of about 21 in terms of the
need for our food banks compared to what
we would have expected on the trend
then the November one we saw a dip of
about 15 compared to what we would have
expected in terms of the number of food
Parcels people needed
and in the most recent one that's just
gone out in April we saw a dip of 23
percent
so it clearly made a significant
difference but what you see is that was
a very short respite so the payments
come out people for between one and
three weeks you see that dip then the
need Shoots up again and in each case it
went back up to as it had been
previously a higher level of need than
the year before
so in the most recent one that's gone
out in April we again we saw that dip it
didn't last very long it lasted a
shorter period of time than the others
but it shot up again so even the first
few weeks this year we are already
seeing levels of need higher than last
year which was itself significantly
higher than the previous year
so I think that they clearly helped they
were delivered you know they went
through they went in a targeted way to
people who really needed them they
landed in people's bank accounts you
didn't have to apply all that was good
but I think what it tells us is that
one-off payments
cannot respond to an ongoing level of
income that's too low to cover the
essentials they can only ever give a
short respite
thank you very much Andy Rose we've seen
a similar picture I think for many
people with a learning disability the
cost of living payments just haven't
reflected the challenges that they've
experienced and we know that 80 of
disabled people have said that they just
haven't been enough to cover their
increased costs as an organization we've
seen a consistent degree of Need for our
for our helpline
for people with a learning disability
their families and carers anecdotally we
know that the cost of living payments
have often either been swallowed up by
one large payment of a
disproportionately high energy bill
because we know people with a learning
disability often have higher energy
needs than non-disabled people or the
cost of living payments have been
defrayed across the wide number of extra
costs that the disabled people have
um we've also found that even when
people have been receipt of the general
cost of living payment the disability
cost of living payment and their full
benefit entitlement they have still had
make profoundly difficult choices about
whether they can
afford their Essentials so in our recent
survey we found that 26 of people with a
learning disability who responded
reported not turning the lights on 35
reported skipping meals and 38 had not
used their heating when they were cold
so I think that just indicates that
hardship for people with a learning
disability has persisted even even with
the cost of living payments
thank you Morgan wild I'm going to add
to the Fairly Bleak chorus from our
colleagues here so I mean just to give
you a sense of context
um we have had probably the bleakis
starts the year as a service that we've
ever seen so we give advice on we give
advice on anything but we roughly give
advice on around 300 different topics
and for over 70 of those issues we've
broken full-time records uh this year
and when put that into context of us
having been around over eight years 80
years we've started at the outset of
World War II it's really something to be
in the bleakest situation for people's
living standards we've ever seen because
of living payments have helped we've
seen a similar temporary dip for people
coming so as to access Crisis Support
that's typically referrals to food banks
like the Trussel trust Network or
charitable grants from local councils or
other Charities you see that dip in the
data for a month and then it goes away
you don't see that dip for our other key
advice areas so for example if you come
to us for a budgeting exercise in debt
advice
we are increasingly seeing that our
advisors even when they're going through
your income through your expenditure of
a fine to from that
tooth comb they can't make the numbers
add up over 50 people coming to us
um in are now in that situation if we're
giving them death advice that's really
quite a bleak overall picture thank you
very much Sunny West and like others I
mean the payments have made important
contribution and I think particularly
combined with the other support that the
government has given with energy bills
but I think the evidence that we're
getting both from the polling that we do
regularly and also from the many many
people that contact us is that for some
people there isn't it isn't sufficient
people are still struggling with bills
um I've been perhaps to sort of pick up
two groups a lot of people tell us that
they've got health conditions or
disabilities they need to keep their
health particularly warm they've got
high laundry bills high costs of extra
food and things and people in those
situations are kind of really really
worrying about
and the fact that they over the winter
they were turning down the heating and
they knew it wasn't doing any good for
their health they knew it was being
affected a woman whose husband had got
dementia saying you know various other
conditions he doesn't understand why we
can't have the house warm enough
um I suppose the other group that seems
to be coming to us increasingly are
people who have a bit of savings or
private pensions and thought that they
had done enough to have a comfortable
retirement not luxurious but get by and
maybe have a bit over for a treat maybe
even say for a holiday and are saying
now all my income is going on my regular
outcomings week got a private pension we
can't get any extra help and for drawing
on savings so I think people worried
about getting by our day-to-day the
weather's obviously getting warmer so
heating isn't such an issue but they're
still worried about the future read
something from a woman in her 80s who'd
said she's drawn had to draw on her
savings she just about survived last
winter but she really really worried
about next winter so worrying about
what's going to happen in the future as
well thank you very much David Lindo
thank you very much so Stephen um let's
start a with hitman's West um does
targeting these cost leveling payments
to those already in receipt of benefits
that we lose most of the leaders
well I think targeting the sort of bulk
of the help to people getting these
tested benefits obviously gets help to
people who are in need by definition
because you have a low income
um what we're finding is they don't
reach everybody in need on a low income
and the two groups that we've
particularly highlighted is those who
should be getting pension credit
um because the people the people that we
deal with pension credit is the main
passporting benefit for cost of living
so the people are missing out because
they haven't claimed pension credit and
I know this is an ongoing issue that the
committee and other people have looked
at but take up remains remains an
important issue and secondly the people
who are just over the pension credit
level and you could be a pound you could
be 10p over the pension credit level and
that gives that Cliff Edge whereas you
don't get the support from the cost of
living payment 650 900 in this year and
people can be worse off because they've
got a small a pension then if they if
they hadn't never saved for that and it
was claiming pension credit
this world yeah so I just I fully
endorse what what Sally has said about
uh pension credit I had two uh further
issues for people who
um aren't being reached one is people
who happen to receive a What's called
the nil award in uh Universal credits uh
at the time for their eligibility for
the cost of living payments uh we've
seen huge numbers of people in that
situation
who haven't been would typically be in
any given month be receiving a universal
who's been sanctioned for example
exactly somebody who's been sanctioned
we have seen cases
um where you know people are working
part-time they're receiving a Universal
Credit payments they cover a couple of
shifts that takes them just over the
threshold and because they're just over
the threshold at their it means that
they aren't eligible in payment it's
been a huge issue and like just that
people don't understand
why they aren't receiving the support
that they're desperately need
the other issue has been people who are
on non-income based benefits so things
like housing benefits on the Legacy
system contributory essay and
contributory JSA who aren't receiving
any other form of income related
benefits like Universal credits those
people haven't been eligible to take
housing benefit for example that
probably affects around 100 000 working
each households around 370 000 pensioner
households many of whom would be
eligible for pension credits we know
that most people in that situation will
be on a low income
um and may be eligible for income
related benefits if they had applied I
think it's worth reflecting on the
contributory benefits specifically
because I think that does create a real
unfairness that if you happen to have
made sufficient National Insurance
contributions to qualify for something
like contributory Esa you've all it's
been a worse position than some of the
on an income based benefits
similar to Sally really we found that
vast numbers of people with the learning
disability have been reached you know
quickly and efficiently through the cost
of living payments but we are concerned
that it hasn't reached everybody and
we're particularly mindful of people
with a learn disability who are in need
are missing out on cost of living
payment support because they aren't
already claiming the benefits that
they're entitled to the barriers that
they experience in the design and
delivery of of the welfare system and so
that's a group that we're really really
concerned about
um so I think that you need to separate
it into two different things so using
social security system to Target people
I think is right you know a lot of work
went into designing a system which would
make sure help gets to people who need
it
I think the difficulty is if we choose
to use that for these one-off payments
what it does is magnifi well it kind of
it magnifies unfairnesses in the system
but also it kind of drives a bit of a
coach and horses through you know
Universal Credit is designed to have the
taper so you're always better off
doing this then undoes that careful
design but that's purely because of the
one-off payment not because we're using
Social Security
the only other group to add to what
colleagues have said that we've heard
people are concerned about missing out
our people with no request public funds
or people waiting to move on to UC
because of immigration status
low income households are not eligible
for the cost of improvement and thinking
specifically of people who are
struggling with in work poverty and
starting with yourself was Bernard um
have you seen more households going
forward not eligible for the cost of
living payment
um struggling more than those who've
received them
um so I would say probably not because
if you're not eligible for the for the
cost of living payments it's because
generally your income is high enough
don't qualify for Universal Credit so I
think you know we do know that people
who are on Universal Credit are much
more likely to be going out without
going without Essentials than people who
aren't
but I think you're right that there is
that group of people who are very
a very small amount above the threshold
or have fluctuating incomes so we do see
a lot of people coming to food banks in
insecure work that seems to be a big
issue and I think you're right these
kinds of one-off payments are going to
be very inconsistent in whether those
people happen to qualify at any one time
okay um is anybody in the panel what I
didn't think into that already I just
found out really endorsed on the points
uh that it makes the the last pound of
universal credits way way too important
uh for people and lots of people rightly
won't have applied uh for both I would
just add that I I really do buy the
points that people just outside the
system uh have struggled a great deal
one of the things that we've argued for
uh
uh sit in
um concerts with the social security
system is to have an energy social
tariff to reflect the fact that this
crisis is not just about incomes it's
about people's situations it's about how
hard their homes are so we heat and you
need a system for making sure those
people uh whether they're inside
Universal Credit or not receive a
support they need just to add to
Morgan's Point um on the impact that
people's situation has we've definitely
found that the need is most acute
amongst people with a learning
disability
um on benefits and in receipt of cost of
living payments but we have seen
families who aren't in receipt of you
know significant State Welfare support
but who have been particularly affected
by high energy bills you know they may
have a child who has a medical condition
um that requires significantly increased
energy and we've heard of some
households who are having energy bills
up to a thousand pounds higher than than
the average so they're experiencing real
hardship and part of that is because
there's a Chasm between the underlying
household incomes of households with a
disability and those without
um the resolution Foundation put the
figure at 44 if disability Social
Security is not included which I think
just exposes the fact that
disabled people are hugely vulnerable to
the rises in cost of Essentials
regardless of if they're in receipt of
high levels of benefit support or not
okay and Stephen I've just got one final
question
very briefly if you would yeah it's just
in relation to that I've seen I can
start into case from Lana sure where
somebody had a joint claim with a then
partner for Universal Credit and a
couple split up and that person was not
eligible for the cost of living payments
um do you have recommendations as to how
we might be able to ensure that those
who miss out on payments can be
supported in the future
I mean I think the main thing is
um don't rely on one-off payments in a
moment of time if we were putting the
money into making the underlying rate of
benefits adequate then I think the
system could deal with that if we're
using one-off payments you will always
get these circumstances of and when it
will be unfair
thank you sister thank you very much
which are better
um the
cost of living payments or an increment
to regular monthly benefits bearing in
mind that the increment during the
pandemic was only paid to Universal
Credit and there is undoubtedly a number
of people who believe that you know the
one-off
uh costs large one-off costs are better
addressed by
um the cost of living payments
I would Echo what Helen has just said
and I think the evidence is pretty clear
that from a policy design better it's
better to have
um increments to Universal credit than a
system of one-off payments that does
have a certain drawbacks so as you
mentioned there were ongoing problems
with the Legacy system uh in trying to
extend the 20 pound uplift to that
system so it may be the case that while
we maintain the Legacy system you need a
parallel system of one-off payments for
them while having
um an uplift for everybody else they
would make the entire process a lot
smoother for their people who are coming
to us and have helped them says it's
would remove a great degree of
arbitrariness and who receives the
payment there are other things that
would need thinking through like
interaction with the benefits tap and
interaction with two child limit
depending on how you applied the
increase
um in the base rate but I think clearly
Superior to
um one-off payments
I think the only thing I would add to
that is I think we need to think about
stability of income as well as amount of
income don't know when people are
getting by on very low levels of income
they are they are doing a lot of
financial juggling they're generally
trying to pay off debts they're trying
to work out which Bill to get into
arrears with at which time they are
doing incredibly tight budgeting and
having this kind of having fluctuating
payments makes that far harder and when
you add into that that most of these
people who are in work many people are
already having to deal with earnings
which are not steady I think we would
want the social security system to help
people stabilize their finances not
create an even more unstable situation
for people makes it very hard to plan
and to budget effectively
thank you very much Steve McKay thank
you I want to ask a couple of quick
questions about the 150 pounds
disability cost of living payment so I
think I want to ask Marty
um you said in an earlier answer there
that you didn't think uh everyone who is
eligible had actually received the
payment are you able to put a figure on
that do you have a a notion of the
numbers or the percentage you missed out
no we're not and like I said you know
we're confident that the vast numbers of
people have received the payment so
eligibility has not been our primary
concern it has been really about the the
payment amount itself and the acceptance
which has essentially been our
inadequate and housing I I just wondered
when you mentioned that if if it was a
significant figure the the other point
is you see the encounty that the 150
pounds is inadequate what would you do
instead
well I think there's two points really I
think if if Government were intending on
making an additional one-off payments
they would need to be a much higher one
and would actually need to be commenced
with the need for people with the
learning disability 100 150 pounds has
been inadequate is effectively just
replaced
um the warm home discount payment that
the many disabled people received and
are now ineligible for since 290 000
people were removed from that scheme um
who normally receive it
um but I think a more sustainable
long-term solution is is obviously those
benefit upgrades that colleagues have
have discussed before those regular
increases in income
would just have a profound effect on
people I just want to put you in this
what is a much higher rate
got to put a figure on it because it
depends on people's needs
um their disabilities then
the suite of government support that's
in place you know if improvements are
made to to local support then that would
obviously an effect on the rate that you
know a suitable rate that we could
suggest so I think
before right yeah I said the number I
think what I would advocate for isn't
kind of an independent
um review of it so that there's a clear
rationale okay that meets the need just
wondering if you either figure in mind I
better leave it there thank you Debbie
Abrams I don't know if Helen wants to to
Carry On from them from from that
because I know um Professor trust and
jrf have been doing a lot around that
doesn't specifically relate to disabled
people but uh but do you want to mention
yes thank you um so we've done research
with Jose Franti foundation and found
that if you're a single person to cover
your basic costs your Essentials so food
basic household goods bills you need 120
pounds a week that's without the
additional costs that disabled people
face I would say that is the absolute
minimum that we would want to see
everyone getting so that people aren't
left you know hungry cold in the dark
which is what we're seeing at the moment
yeah I'll just add on that I think one
thing it would be useful to understand
from the government is what kind of
process they went uh through to come up
with the estimates of 150 pounds for
disabled people in case you know
relatively well understood what the
additional costs are for disabled people
along a variety of different impairments
and certainly we have seen that the cost
of living crisis for Citizens advice
clients
um has been overwhelmingly driven by
difficulty so if you come to Citizens
advice and you're disabled you are more
likely to come to us about a cost of
living issue than you are any other
problem thank you Maddie can I just pick
up and get a you mentioned before in
terms of the scope extra cost report and
so on and it has gone up dramatically
hasn't it
um
1122 pounds a month extra cost if you
consider inflation as well we know that
one in three disabled people will be
living in poverty double that of
non-disabled people does the 150 pounds
extra I mean we welcome it with the 150
pounds uh extra cost for uh in terms of
disability cost of living payment
doesn't really touch the sides does it
no no not at all it's equivalent to 2.88
per week
um which just isn't clearly not
commensurate with the knee particularly
when we you know if you're mindful of
the extra cost that people the learning
disability have and how they've just
been disproportionately impacted by the
cost of living crisis particularly on on
two measures of household income one
food we know that people to learn the
best people with a learning disability
tend to have you know certain foods they
need to have because of medical or
sensory needs and a lot of those costs
are fixed and so household expenditure
can't be changed so that's been really
impactful and then again yes secondly on
energy we know that many disabled people
have significantly increased energy
needs and can't cut down on those
because they might be using energy for
mobility and hygiene needs
winning electric wheelchairs always more
frequent use of washing machines running
vital medical equipment oxygen
concentrators ventilators feeding tubes
which I just vital and can't be switched
off
um and then other other needs that
pertain to health conditions
um people's homes might need to be
heated to a certain temperature or
people might be experiencing an
increased energy costs of overnight or
24-hour carers so all of that has kind
of created this perfect storm where
people with a learned disability are
disproportionately impacted by the cost
within crisis but we're also starting
this whole crisis from a place of real
economic inequality like you said more
likely to experience poverty
having to contend with those significant
extra costs in the disability prize tag
but again with the group that we we
support people with a learning
disability have few opportunities paid
work so they can increase their
household income so you know they're
just far more less able to waste money
that's really briefly so Stephen child
poverty statistics came out this week
we've seen a massive increase
in in many areas it's not uniform across
across the UK in my own constituency
it's nearly one in two children will be
living in input
um
the big increase even as you all know is
the increase in in children living in
poverty and Working Families up to more
than seven in ten seven and ten
um
and destitutional level uh poverty so
what difference has the cost of living
payment made to to child poverty
who wants to tackle that one very
quickly because I don't know the
patients of the chair
so I would say it has certainly helped
those families that have got it but of
course it's a flat payment
um it's not calibrated for the number of
people you're trying to feed so it has
clearly gone less far if you're a family
with children than if you're a single
person or a couple
um and I think it's worth saying so with
the food bank statistics we've seen a
faster rise in need among families with
children than we have among families
without children
um so I think I mean that's obviously
another argument to use the system as
it's designed because it has built-in
calibration to family size and so on
is single parents
the thing that jumped out in our depth
more than anything else we see a vastly
disproportionate number of people
um who are single parent families
telling us to us for crisis for all
coming to us because they can't make
their budget add up yeah it'd be useful
and I don't please answer this but to
get some figures in terms of how the
essentials guarantee may impact on on
reducing that child poverty level thank
you sir Stephen very much Celine Saxby
thank you and good morning my question
specifically to you Sally is about um
following on from the written evidence
that we received it said that many of
those eligible for pension credit don't
receive it and as a result miss out on
cost of living payments on top from your
experience do you have any indication of
how many people that is or the
proportion of Pensions it's impacting
please well the latest
now come of years out of date in 1919 or
2019-2020 and that was about a third of
pensioners who should be getting pension
credit missing out that's um nearly 800
pensioner families
um since then they probably take up has
increased a bit but we don't think
there's been huge inroads into that it
would be good to have some more
up-to-date figures but yes I think we
can say that it continues to be a kind
of a big a big problem people not
claiming pension credit and indeed other
benefits that they're entitled to and
the government's obviously runs a
significant schemes and I obviously I
represent all them and so I have a lot
of pensioners in my own patch and I have
done numerous photo shoots with the
pension minister to try and actually put
this out just to try and encourage those
people that haven't come forward and
we've obviously had evidence here before
but do you have any other thoughts is
that helping or is there another way
that we can reach these people to
persuade them to apply for what they're
entitled to I mean I think really
positive that the last sort of Yale so
the government has been going out
proactively with messages about
encouraging people to claim and you know
a lot of the messages that we put out
are kind of similar we can work together
using the sort of deadline for the
prevention Credit in order to get the
cost of living payment has been a really
useful hook and that's really important
for awareness raising which we need to
continue doing I don't think of
awareness raising on itself is going to
reach everybody because it's not just
about knowing that a benefit like
pension credit exists you've got to know
that it applies to you and your own
particular circumstances you've got to
know where you can get help if you need
it and there are other barriers around
people not wanting to ask for help or
you know older people say oh this people
were softer than me you know I'll just
turn the heating down so what we think
that the government could do is first of
all well use data matching more to
identify people are missing out and also
making the systems more joined up so in
terms of data matching
ideally people will just see pension
credit
but we know that government doesn't have
all the information you know there isn't
all the information wouldn't be able to
tell you exactly who could get pension
credit and how much they could get but
if you think of the data that hmrc have
that DWP have the local
authorities have if all that could be
sort of used to try to pinpoint those
who are most likely to be entitled and
then you could Target them with very
clear information saying you know we
know that you've got this kind of
pension you know that we get this we
think it's very likely that you'll get x
amount of pension credit this is where
you can get help and support to claim so
we think it'd be really useful to have a
project that look at to the extent that
government can use existing data to
identify and then really Target
um
information and support to people I
think the second thing is looking how
systems work and in particular I'm
thinking of the three main means tested
benefits for pensioners which are
pension credit housing benefit and
council tax reduction so they're the
three benefits that people may be able
to get in order to to help with their
sort of daily living and their housing
costs but they're not fully joined up
even though the rules they're based on
similar rules council tax rebate
councils can set their own rules but not
for pensioners it's a standard rule for
pensions housing benefit is National
rules if you apply for pension credit
the information can be passed to the
local Authority you've still got to make
a claim within a certain time and then
that information is there but you've
still got to go through another step if
you apply for council tax rebate or
housing benefit that information isn't
then passed to pension credit even if
it's all the information that pension
service needs to work out your claim so
some local authorities will be doing
exercises to look at their data and
identify people who are maybe entitled
and again they would have to go and say
you know make a claim for pension
service but it just feels like you know
those three benefits should be a lot
more joined up so that you know if you
approach either the local Authority all
the pension services you provide all the
data needed to make the claim your
entitlement for the three benefits
should be worked out and thank you for
that and do you have any thoughts on
what would be the best way for the
government to support those pensioners
who just miss out on those cost of
living payments yeah this is such a big
issue and as they've mentioned earlier
people who perhaps got a small amount of
say against them just over the pension
credit rate this includes quite a lot of
people who are getting housing medical
council tax rebate as I mentioned and I
mean we feel the best way is to extend
payments to people getting all of those
needs tested benefits I mean we have had
people coming to us to say well you know
I've heard the government's saying there
are these extra payments for people
getting means tested benefits you know
it says on the government website
housing benefit is means tested but I'm
told I can't receive anything so I think
because these are means test its
benefits and that would help take that
extra support a bit sort of slightly
bigger a bigger group thank you and
thank you chair thank you Sally can I
just do you think a significant number
of pensioners have applied for pension
Credit in order to qualify for the cost
of living payment
I think it's certainly been a good
figure to
income claim we have had certainly at UK
we've had more people coming for help
some of them will undoubtedly go on to
make a claim for pension credit
increasingly our local advisors are
saying people are coming to us for help
we'd normally do a benefit check but
this time we can't offer anything extra
so it's difficult to know and of course
the government information
they can tell you how many additional
how many claims were made in a month
they can't tell you which ones were
successful for pension credit you know
the it's it would be a
very good to be able to judge how
successful takeout campaigns and
different initiatives are but the
systems don't seem to allow that
okay thank you Siobhan Bailey thank you
thank you chair sorry about my voice
it's on it's on the way out
um uh on um so we've kind of touched on
the fact that Government tried to get
money out quickly and in doing so
they've created a simple basically
simple payment system and using a
mechanism that's already there which is
the benefit system which is imperfect
but it was for Speed
um so I'm kind of interested to know
from all of you whether you would
sacrifice speed of payments to a for an
attempt to be more bespoke and bring in
change is sort of a targeted size of
household for example and whether you
think that's important
and whether that you think that could be
accurately done at scale so just to go
to Morgan first yeah sure so I think it
could be accurately done at stale and
the reason is
um if you take Universal credits by
itself they're maybe more complexities
but a legacy system but take Universal
Credit by itself there's no there is
basically two ways that you could
increase Universal credits to achieve
the same facts as a cost living payments
you could just increase the standard
allowance by an equivalent amount or you
could if you were more concerned about
staling payments with household size and
other characteristics you could grow
each of the elements of Universal Credit
proportionately so that you are giving
additional thoughts in the way that is
um wouldn't be on a one-off this is on a
on a more free graph but on a one-off
basis do you think there is a mechanism
I think you could could do this on a
one-off obviously
I think everybody here is would also be
overview that a permanent increase is
required because benefit rates are too
low but you could do this on a temporary
basis as we did with the 20 pound uplift
Maddie yeah I would Echo everything that
Morgan said I think
it would just be really key to contend
with those complexities that individuals
who receive Legacy payments
um experience and I think it would just
really depend on how it was
operationalized um but we would be
really Keen to see that permanent
increase in the benefit rate just
because it's it's so inadequate at the
moment for people with a learning
disability
yeah nominal deck over I think one of
the benefits of Universal Credit is it
is very flexible
um so you can use to do an uplift very
quickly which as we saw during the
pandemic it's only the Legacy benefits
where you have to do something more
clunky and it takes longer
but I I mean happily I don't think
that's now a choice the government has
to make for most people they don't have
to choose between speed and accuracy
because the system will let you do both
is your view is that the payments should
be adjusted for household and youth is
that is what you were saying about
families and people presenting to the
food banks at the moment yeah so if you
run it through Universal Credit you can
just use the existing system so you can
increase the standard allowance and the
child element for instance
and that would enable you to
um to direct those payments I mean one
thing that was very welcome was the
government that ensure that they lifted
the benefit cap so that people didn't
miss out on extra help because they had
hit that arbitrary limit so you would
need to do that as well but I think the
system is in general well designed to do
what we need it to
perhaps not um not necessarily something
for your clientele most older people
living single person a couple households
so I'll leave that one if your view of
policy do you think that if we made the
adjustment for households you think that
it would then have an impact on single
age working households
um a single person working households do
you think there will need to be a
trade-off because the payments couldn't
continue across I suppose it's
adjustment made reduced the amount for
sort of people on their own we yeah
wouldn't support that because often your
costs higher but I think probably
looking at giving extra support to
larger households so that would kind of
be a be a different issue thank you
thank you thank you very much Neil coin
thanks sir and Morgan you you painted
the most Stark picture of the situation
facing people across the country
um I think you said it was the bleakest
incentive device history including
during the second World War how do you
square that with closing the advice
Bureau the blue in Berman's ear my
constituency which serves quite a
disadvantaged community
oh we I would have to look at the
specifics of that situation but uh the I
mean the challenges that we face as a
service are extraordinary you know we
have vastly more demand than we are able
to offer advice and funding has been on
under continuous pressure so we're
always looking for opportunities to make
sure that we can reduce costs
um where possible while maintaining the
overall level of provision for our
services
I think the device turnovers 150 354
million pounds last year and the mission
statement is you won't struggle to get
help from us so I just I just wonder if
you could share perhaps uh chair I
appreciate it's not
um perhaps relevant to the whole
committee you could share some
information about what other options
were considered locally if the rent was
the primary issue for the move then I
wonder if there were other means of
keeping a local facility that I'd be
very happy to support if I can I think
it's an excellent service and I'm very
concerned about the loss to my community
and but I wanted to ask about the number
of organizations including child poverty
Action Group and entitled to have
expressed concern about the Clifford
nature of the eligibility criteria for
cost of living payments this has been
touched on already but I wonder do any
of your organizations have data on the
number of people you're seeing affected
by that specific issue
a not specific data but it's certainly
um a huge uh problem we're seeing lots
of people for whom they are just outside
uh the threshold for receiving uh
Universal credits and therefore being
ineligible for cost of living payments I
think it's probably the central issue
that we see it's been touched on that
people coming to food banks and you're
saying there's a huge number but but how
do you know what's the how is it logged
in your system that these are people who
should qualify for support aren't quite
getting it and then how are you turning
that into recommendations for how to
improve the system who else is it that
would warrant better support I think I
think Morgan you such an energy in
someone else touched on single parents
but
how you what is the database for the
recommendation what is the
recommendation please so I can touch on
um our data that others will have
um talents as well the driving factor in
our data that's
um informs what do you think about this
is people who are in what we call their
negative budgets so people who come to
us they go through the full data Vice
process
they are we go through their income and
expenditure fine tooth fair and still
can't make their budgets add up for lots
of those people they sh are on a low
income but not receiving a cost of
living payments
um and it seems
very
when you look at their situation uh it
looks very reasonable that because
of heating costs because of how this
crisis has been driven by the energy
crisis there needs to be some solution
that captures those group of people
so I say from our experience so the vast
majority of people who are forced to
turn to food banks are on a means tested
benefit
but it is not enough for them to afford
Essentials that's why they're there
but it's also no schools that an
enormous proportion are not receiving
all of what you would expect because
they are affected by debt deductions
that source uh by the cap by the two
child limit or by sanctions
um so I think there is there is that
problem that even if you're on the
benefit you may not actually be getting
everything that the system has assessed
you is needing what I would say though
is the other what we do see is the
majority of people coming to food banks
are disabled and most of those who
aren't living with someone who is it's
an enormous driver but many of those
people are not getting any disability
related benefits
um now we obviously don't know for sure
how many should be but it is
particularly problems getting pip so a
lot of the financial inclusion advice
that we we're giving through food banks
is trying to help people get PIP and I
know for the work we do with systems
advice with the helpline that we run
jointly that is I think the top benefit
issue so I think getting access to
disability benefits is one of the
biggest drivers of people ending up in
this situation
and I would add to that that we also
find a lot of older people are missing
out on attendance allowance so we've
talked about pension credit take up
which is getting more attention but the
other benefits like attendance and outs
and like people also and we don't have
figures for them but we know just from
our day-to-day advice um services that
people are missing out on that just in
terms of so I was going to say in terms
of the numbers
um just above pension credit for
perspective of older people and I was
saying earlier that we'd like to see
cost of living payments extended to
people who are getting housing benefit
in council tax and reduction looking at
the figures it looks like that might be
around
400 and 100 400 000 pensioners who are
getting a means test to benefit but not
pension credit or pensioner households
but I can send you some information
about those figures but that would be
really helpful and do any of your
organizations support the child poverty
action groups um suggestion that those
who apply for but what nil Awards in
Universal Credit get help as well is
this something that there is a consensus
on in the sector yes yeah that looks
positive thank you thank you pretty much
can I just ask
ing a question I put to Sally have you
seen people
applying for benefit in order to get the
cost of living payment I mean it has has
this been a helpful for benefit take up
this size so I if I look at our data
before the cost of living crisis we were
helping around uh 10 000 people a month
with a general benefits entitlement
advice so that's gone up to around 20
000 a month so it has been a really big
increase partly that's driven just by
general cost of living concerns and
people wanting to make sure that they
are claiming benefits that they
otherwise wouldn't
anecdotally our advisors say a big
driver has been
um
putting them in a position to claim cost
of living payments right
the only so we haven't seen particularly
uh it driving take up but one thing to
mention is the DWP doesn't publicize
which day yeah what is the qualifying
day and if the government was going to
go down this route again one thing they
could do would actually be to publicize
what what is the qualifying day because
that could then be used as a call to
action by people across the sector to
say we've got to get you on this by this
day and that might be a more purposeful
way to try and do that I mean we know
what is it about 19 billion pounds of
benefits go unclaimed each year it's
about seven and a half billion for
Universal Credit so there are a lot of
people missing out on all the support in
addition to these extra payments the
advantage with pension credit is because
you can get three months about dated
payments we have been able to say make a
claim by a certain date which indeed the
DWP has done it as well so I said
earlier it's a very good hook to get
publicity around and benefits going
unclaimed Morgan in the citizens advice
case are people coming to you because of
the cost of living things because it's
in their mind that could be aware than
getting that or is it once they've come
in the advisors say actually you could
you could qualify as you'd expect it's a
bit of a mix so we'll see both kinds of
cases okay some people at least are
aware that this is an opportunity yeah
okay thank you very much Nigel Mills
and we've talked over the years about
the danger of Cliff edges and
I mean have those dangers come to pass
have we seen people trying to avoid
taking extra hours to make sure they
don't max out there you see that month
and miss out on 300 odd quid tax-free
and have we seen Strange Behaviors
creeping into the system that we
probably didn't really want to see
and so if people were like fully
informed and following these things in
as much detail as the rest of us would
be the rational thing to do
particularly to Helen's point but they
don't advertise
um the take-up date would be to suppress
your income in the period where you know
that a cost of living payment
eligibility criteria is likely to fall
that'd be the sensible thing
um to do giving the scale of money
involved and so you would expect it to
have a potential chilling effect and run
contrary to the very good intentions of
Universal Credit and making sure that
you are never worse off for earning an
additional payout now in practice
people probably aren't on average
following with a degree of
um uh
detail that those of us around this room
would but you know some people will be
and it's it's yeah it's just a it's a
very bad property of a policy system uh
to encourage uh that kind of behavior
from people
and I would only add that
most of the people we're talking about
are in a fairly dire situation and if
every week you are struggling to put
food on the table and keep the lights on
and seeing your bills and debt mounting
up
I would be very surprised if there are
people who have who could be earning
more who decide not to that week or that
couple of weeks I think people don't
have the level of financial buffer that
would lead you to make those kinds of
decisions
so the government
in response to this crisis was a I
remember these things now we had the
funny council tax in Reverse thing which
worked quite well if you're on Direct
debit was a bit fiddlier if you weren't
we then had the
money back from your energy bill can't
be spent over six months we then had the
cost of living payments and we then have
the capping of your
Energy bill directly by your supplier
Supply if we're going to have another
heaven forbid another crisis like this I
mean which of those do you think
actually was the right way to go about
helping people I mean is it a
combination of
capping the bill and then support for
those who can't afford the difference or
did you prefer one of the other options
that was there
if we could not do the council tax
rebates again that would be much
appreciated I think at the time we
called it strange complicated and
untargeted and I think it's
um was probably a policy instrument that
we should put back
um on the other options but I think what
what we've ended up doing has been more
expensive than it needed to be because
we have instantiated a energy price
guarantee for everyone and then
supplemented it with cost of living
payments for those on lowest incomes and
we've done it in uh quite a I would say
on strategic way it's been going from
crisis to crisis rather than addressing
the underlying cause I think if we were
to face this
situation again and I certainly wouldn't
that against us needing a third round of
cost of living support it would be much
better to put in place a proper energy
social tariff which is reflective of
um the energy costs that people have
based on that household characteristics
um
at a property condition and that can
reach out into further up into the
middle of the income distribution
because when energy bills go up as
dramatically as they do the demand for
support won't just be needed by the
importance in society it'll be needed
much higher up as well
yes I mean we certainly support the idea
of a social tough I guess you do need a
combination of measures so the social
tariff is about reducing costs for those
with the hardest to heat houses and the
lowest incomes and then you need to look
at sort of decent incomes
um although I think you know it's not
ideal to be giving one-off lump sums and
we've talked quite a bit about
um you know the need for a regular
income they you know as they have been
important for for people and they have
got some money out to a lot of people
quite quickly so ideally you wouldn't
need further rounds of one-off sums but
they do serve a purpose and maybe they
will be needed
you know I say we should we should try
and learn from our experience we've
tried quite a lot of different things in
the last few years and rather than
repeat any of them so you know council
tax thing was obviously a disaster and
we should just all collectively forget
about it
um I think we've also learned that
something something that's fully
Universal
um just meant lots and lots of people
got the money who genuinely didn't need
it we've learned that one-off payments
help for a very short time but don't
actually help people get get stable and
be able to afford things
I think what we learned from the 20
pound uplift during the pandemic was
we've had really good analysis analysis
of that and that made such a big
difference to Poverty to hardship that
to all sorts of things the only downside
was it was again a flat rate but I think
what we've in a sense what we've learned
from all of these things is that we
should use the tools that are designed
for the job which is the benefit system
and we should run whatever money we've
got through that and then something like
a social tariff can take care of those
people in the middle that we shouldn't
be funneling lots of money to to be
honest because most of the time they
don't need it but where there are kind
of pockets of people who do you can pick
it up through that
I would echo echo um Helen's point but I
think it's key as well to to draw out
the fact that on in these additional
measures that we're discussing like the
social tariff
um we need to think about those design
elements that um contend with the needs
of people the learning disability so for
example it needs to be automated it
needs to be easy for people to access
because we've seen the problems that
have come to pass When government
support and for example the energy bill
support schemes
um there's been significant
accessibility barriers for people with a
learning disability which has mean that
they've been disadvantaged and haven't
received the amount of support that that
they maybe should have
sort of intrigued that
like rightly we don't like the idea of
asking councils
deal with this even though they should
know
people in their area and they should be
kind of like relatively benevolent
organizations being public sector but we
think asking energy companies to work
out which households to Target based on
the quality of their housing how many
people in there what sort of income they
have is a realistic thing you can roll
out quickly it kind of feels quite hard
yeah it's definitely not a realistic
thing to roll out quickly the data on uh
property characteristics is collected
already by the evaluation office agency
um under what was formerly based on I'm
not sure where it sits now
um so all of that data exists and it's
already used in matching for the warm
home discounts uh there are additional
um complexities mostly in reaching
Beyond Universal Credit because that
would require integration with hmrc data
potentially but the
um the principle of being able to Target
based on how hard a home is to heat is
fairly well established on the council
tax that's uh reduction
um part I think the the key difficulty
was in uh both in how payments were
processed if you earn in direct debits
payments as you mentioned also the
imperfect uh grading of different homes
leading to lots of people being left out
I think there is a place for local
welfare assistance through continuation
and boosting of household support fund
for people in crisis situations but that
should principally be for people in
crisis rather than what we've seen which
is Grants to help people with their
ordinary living costs
one of our favorite topics we come back
I mean this was an inflation crisis
and benefits
generally go up by inflation I mean it
have we just exposed the fact that
putting up benefits in April via the
inflation number in September is
actually not a particularly useful way
of trying to keep something that's meant
to provide a standard of living to keep
up with the standard of living that you
want if you're always quite so far
behind and quite so unresponsive to it
yeah I mean it is I think for a lot of
periods of History it's been fine
because inflation just hasn't changed
that much but you're right this has
exposed the fact that in an unusual
period you can get these effects I mean
I think there is a the government does
have the ability to choose to put it up
by more than the previous September's
inflation it's entirely in their gift to
say we will actually put it up by the
current inflation for instance and the
way that UC works there's no technical
reason you couldn't do that
um so I think in a sense it's a kind of
political choice
how you want to kind of spread that
spending yeah so yeah I think um if you
look at the historical events that
September doesn't have any kind of
special Magic Properties as a month to
uh look at inflation in fact I think it
was mostly chosen because historically
under the Legacy system it genuinely was
more difficult we've got a good system
now so let's use that flexibility to
increase benefits in a way that isn't
just tied to the idea of look at a
single month's inflation that actually
involves a degree of judgment about what
was the inflation landscape look like
are we expecting bills to continue going
up for a longer period well then let's
make sure that we're over aiming uh on
increasing benefits
I mean I think having that six months
as I said it's particularly unfortunate
at the time when bills absorbed so much
um and sometimes it works in people's
favors to be honest inflation can fall
but I mean it's been really serious this
year and it feels like six months or to
at least be reduced a bit even you could
get the same kind of system DWP may tell
you that's not possible but it just
feels like they ought to be able to get
a gap shelter
thank you very much that concludes the
questions we wanted to put to you thank
you all very much Lee for joining for
the very helpful information you've
given
thank you if you'd like to step down
for joining us I think you've all heard
the earlier session as well so that's a
useful background for the discussion
we're going to have can I ask each of
you as I did the first panel to very
briefly tell us who you are starting
with Maxwell Marlow hi I'm Maxwell
Marlow I'm director of research at the
Adam Smith Institute cute Fran Bennett
I'm Fran Bennett associate fellow at the
department of social policy and
intervention University of Oxford thank
you and Richard Hunt I'm and I'm head of
catering hospitality and Country parks
for leicestershire County Council you've
come a long way today so we're grateful
to you we're grateful to all of you can
I put the first question to you and ask
each of you to say what you make of the
the way the cost of living support
payments were targeted
do you think it was effective the
targeting do you think it could have
been done better
I saw Marlo
well uh yes I the belief of Institute
essentially these were quite effective
payments that were put out in the timely
and
um well High take-up manner essentially
given the fact that there wasn't
uh
um there wasn't specific targeting and
you obviously had to be in the system in
the first place
um I think it was quite well targeted
areas
um that needed it the most
um and from what we kind of saw over the
uh period of the cost of living crisis
is essentially that
um where the money went it did fill the
uh some of the gaps that were left
um reading some of the evidence that's
been submitted to the committee
beforehand uh we were particularly happy
about the fact it was kind of a lump sum
payment that was given out it was quite
good for individual households to
essentially look at their bills look at
what their plans were and better
allocate the money to where it should go
that was very encouraging and we were
quite happy to see that
thank you
thank you I mean I think we want to try
and not repeat what's been said in
several sessions already about the
impact of these payments
um so just to summarize I think cash
first is the best approach for a start
and obviously as child poverty Action
Group said at speed and at scale was
possible with the ad hoc payment system
that the government's got but that's
also got limitations uh particularly in
terms of the qualifying period and also
in terms of as has been said this
morning
um the one payment per benefit unit
which I think is a is a real issue also
it's got problems because of the
algorithm for the Universal Credit
calculation which in itself needs to be
looked at and the cuts in the benefit
system already
so benefit cap to child limit local
housing allowance under 25s which are
therefore implicit in using the current
benefit system to help with cost of
living the inadequate amount already
which people have said the take-up
problem the government is no longer
publishing figures on any working age
take-up of benefits
um and of course we we've got the
household support fund as well and I'll
I'll leave Richard to talk about that
the government has said it will evaluate
the cost of living payments so I think a
useful recommendation by the committee
would be that it should publish that
evaluation
um so I think that would be very helpful
and I mean it's just worth saying
um that Universal payments actually
Target all those in need better than any
means tested payments happen to do
thank you and Richardson and I think I
can only Echo what others have said that
that sort of our our feeling has been
that it's been something of a blunt
instrument perhaps and that there's
there's methods that offer more Nuance
around how support can be offered and
that the household support fund has been
a good example of that
yeah
it just tells a little bit more about
the household support for how how
effective has that been in in
leicestershire in reaching people yeah
so so in leicestershire
um I mean every household support fund
is different it's money given by
Department of work and pensions to top
tier local authorities
um and leicestershire's approach it's
had six elements to it which has ranged
from support for children on free School
meals in the holidays through to allow
um support food banks to purchase food
for distribution
um also allowing Charities to purchase
energy efficient white goods to give to
people in need to again lower their
energy costs
um but then that one of the biggest bits
we do as a referral scheme for support
with food and fuel vouchers and so and
uh the current iteration of the
household support fund that started in
April and runs for the next 12 months
we've allocated three million pounds to
that and the way our schemes worked at
leicestershire is that rather than in
rather than individuals or households
applying to us for support through that
scheme instead they work with agencies
they're already working with and those
agencies are a referring body into the
scheme in leicestershire so do we feel
that we've got this group of well over
175 referring bodies now in the county
who are already working with clients
already working with households who are
in need of support and referring them
through to to us for support with the
household support scheme
um we know this way we're picking up
people who fall through some of the
cracks some of the people who may be
subject to some of the cliff edges that
were talked about here in in the earlier
session and things like that so again
there's that kind of nuance applied
there
um uh and um we sort of set out the
broad eligibility criteria within our
policies but our household support fund
has been very much set up around
trusting professionals to make the
decision over whether someone requires
referral and requires support
um so again we kind of think it's it's
accommodating a breadth of need that
perhaps isn't isn't offered otherwise
and for us one of the things we're
really proud of is that we know that
everyone engaging with that system
because they're engaging with a
referring body is getting that ongoing
support as well so this isn't simply
money that's given to a household and
that's that because they have to have
that form of referral it means that
um that there's a longevity to it
um and certainly even when they're
referred through and received the money
from us within the local Authority
that's processed by a part of by a part
of our Public Health Department who will
ensure that people will refer to us get
a telephone call and a chance to discuss
with them and whether they are taking up
the correct amount of benefits to which
they're entitled also maybe a referral
through to the warm home scheme within
the local Authority or any other support
that can be offered and that's something
I think a lot of local authorities are
very concerned about is that the cost of
living payments are all time limited and
we're all very concerned about what
happens at the end of all of those so
we've been working really hard to build
that sustainability in so that when you
know if and when these payments come to
an end people aren't just left
Stephen I think we're all quite well
versed now on the kind of Cliff Edge
nature of these payments indeed has been
I think you took part in a joint
committee session between ourselves and
treasury on Cliff edges
um
I mean given the the kind of
clefage nature of the eligibility
criteria
um does this mean that the kind of the
blunt cut off generally Works given the
number of payments issued and we'll
start with Maxwell and work well I could
just repeat that last point please so
given the the kind of Eligibility
criteria and the fact that there's a
cliff Edge built into it that does that
blunt cut off generally work given the
number of payments that are issued yeah
absolutely
um we have done quite a bit of research
on the nature of Cliff edges within the
fiscal system
um a lot of it to do with the
Chancellor's recent uh Child Care
reforms um and seeing that essentially
you know people receiving the benefits
are and these payments are you know
they're smart people and they you know
have their have the data in front of
them essentially looking at the bills
coming out and as was echoed on the last
panel that last pound really is very
very important and um so I think we may
come on to later having a little bit
more of a smart system with a better
tape rate a little better adjusted more
accurate and would definitely help
make the system a bit more dynamic
because when we although the department
hasn't released all the data yet and
it's definitely a recommendation that
they're much more transparent
um on what's the data coming out of this
will be and released in a much shorter
time period
um it's certainly the case that I think
when we look back on this
um as Lessons Learned there will be a
significant deficit essentially between
people who would have been eligible but
have essentially
in circumstances not owing to you know
they're trying very hard to you know put
food on the table Etc
um we essentially will see a large
drop-off in the kind of take a break of
that and it is it's it's made people
worse off unfortunately and I think it's
quite bad for the economy overall and
for communities around the country
is better
um I think there was quite a lot said
both in the treasury select committee at
which some of you were present
um and also just now in terms of the
previous session uh about Cliff edges so
I won't go on about that I mean one of
them that wasn't mentioned was
um it may depend uh on the accident of
timing in terms of How likely your you
are to get payments of course
um but I think the as I say I think that
the nature of Cliff edges has been
adequately
um covered by other people I mean
obviously the one-off payments
um were able to be quick accurate
straightforward but it also is worth
saying I think that both with the
household support fund uh if Richard
doesn't mind me saying so I'm with the
um completely separate ad hoc payment
system that the DWP has actually
developed this is complexifying the
benefit system further when of course uh
Universal Credit was meant to be
simplifying it and Universal payments
are simple
um like child benefit for example used
to be
um so I think we're we're actually
developing parallel systems of giving
people awards
um which we might well look at in future
and say we should take them back down
again to a few simpler systems rather
than the accretions that have been
happening over the last few months I
mean understandably so the other thing I
just wanted to say was I mean the
government was doing uh the one-off
payments partly because of a timing it
was quicker to do to use the ad hoc
payment system that they've developed
than it was to do other things but they
did cost of living payments in 2022 and
they could have as child poverty action
groupers said could have rethought them
for
2023-24 and and didn't really they they
went on with the same system
um so I think that's uh that's worth
querying a bit
I don't know you're going to disagree
with Ms Bennett and say that I actually
know the system is much much simpler now
and easier from the county council's
point of view I'm not sure the County
Council would have an opinion over
whether it adds complexity I suppose
what local authorities would argue is
that because we know our local
communities very well what schemes like
our supporters or support funds allowed
us to do is to be very targeted in our
approach and I think that's something
that a lot of people have echoed today
is that these Pro these schemes lack
that targeting and local government's
quite well placed to offer some of that
could I just could I just clarify what I
said therefore I'm certainly not arguing
against the need for one-off lump sum
emergency payments in crisis we had the
local welfare assistance scheme we still
have the local welfare assistance scheme
money could have been put into that to
expand it and we need long-term
sustainable funding for one-off
emergency payments for people as well I
certainly wouldn't argue against that
whether it's done at local or national
level is a different issue but since
we've got the local welfare assistance
scheme we ought to be looking at the
fact that the funding is no longer ring
fenced for that and 35 I think councils
have actually stopped doing a local
welfare assistance scheme completely
including my own County Council of
Oxfordshire although the new regime is
probably going to reintroduce it but
that that might have been used and
should certainly be be
sustainably built up in future
thank you so Steve just picking up that
point Frank I mean the household support
Fund in effect provided additional
resources for local welfare assistance
well that's kind of what I mean although
I think probably household support fund
uh was also
given out by the county councils or the
other District Council levels that
didn't have a well local welfare
assistance scheme anymore
okay
um something thank you and good morning
and how else do you think the government
could better support those households in
need of financial aid for Essentials
during this cost of living crisis we'd
like to go first
I'm happy to go first on this
um it's may fall outside of the remit of
the committee but there's quite a lot of
general tax reform that could take place
um
if you're you know humor me for a bit um
you know stuff like fuel duty is very
high and unfortunately the government's
public transport provision isn't that
good outside of metropolitan areas so a
lot of households need to drive some way
to get to work and get to school you
know medical appointments to you know
facilitate care and the obr puts fuel
duty at a cost of 867 pounds per
household that quite a lot of money if
you're already incredibly tight on your
budget and UK already has some of the
highest fuel Duty rates in Europe if not
the world so we definitely encourage
people to encourage government sorry to
have another look at that especially
given
um you know people and metropolitan
areas can walk or bike or take the tube
to work and it's just not the same
outside outside in the regions
um other things such as
um kind of food and drink taxes the more
targeted stuff um you take a kind of
decile look at the uh you know the
people in the economy you see
essentially people from the 10th to the
7th decile about 14 on average of their
household budget goes towards food and
the government is moving ahead with
Banning buy one get one free meals
um in October which has been quite
criticized I'd say not more outside of
Public Health authorities but you're
essentially taking food off the table
for families and I don't think that's
the right thing to be doing actually
given the crisis that we're in at the
moment
um and also the government has moved has
suggested price controls
um we've been saying for some time in
fact we've published a book and when we
first opened as a think tank in 1977
called 10 000 years of price controls
and they have failed everywhere they've
even tried and the reason that is is
essentially you're creating shortages
and again
um taking food off the table and off the
shelves it's going to affect those uh
poor Eastern Society the most
um because if you're you know if you've
got more money you can obviously very
easily go to other places to buy more
food and so obviously the shortages
created a very bad and finally and this
is kind of again someone outside of it
we would like to see thresholds raised
for National Insurance and we'd also
like to have the personal allowance
indexed unfrozen
um if you look at when the personal
allowance was Frozen
um a few years ago if you take a kind of
CPI inflation and you add that into the
model essentially the purse allowance
should go up from about 12 000 pounds up
to about 17 000 pounds that's five
thousand pounds saved
um four households well actually
individual earners
um that would obviously overrun the uh
one payment the single payments have
been put forward by the government
during this period it's also bad for
productivity in the long run health of
the economy so I do understand that this
is somewhat outside the remit of the
committee but obviously the uh the
welfare system we have is very much in
uh you know locked in essentially to
this
um to this wider economic Malaysia that
we're seeing across the country and
indeed across the world
um
I think the problem about asking about
Alternatives is that there's a huge
Spectrum
from the things that we were talking
about so I think Nigel Mills himself
actually suggested the two-month
qualifying period rather than one month
for the cost of living payments for
example right up to I thought it was
going to be just a whole new benefit
system but actually a whole new tax
system as well
um so I think it's quite a hard question
sir so
yeah I could just say a few principles I
think in terms of making the the benefit
system in particular more more sensitive
one would be the family size issue which
or family and family size issue which I
think has been revealed by the ad hoc
payments
um as as an issue but was already an
issue so we've had the two child limit
we've had the benefit cap which
particularly affects families as well
and we've also had the not just the
uplift but also the ad hoc payments
um none of those taking account of of
whether you've got children or not and I
think that's a real issue it's a
direction of our benefit system in which
I would not like to see us go any
further and I would like to see us draw
back from that and I think we may be
going to talk about International
examples it's it's not common
internationally for that to be happening
the other thing which may be not so
obvious I think is the is the household
unit and particularly the household unit
for payment for Universal Credit and I
think refuge in its written evidence
talked about this to you in terms of
looking at uh individual
um payment as well as the household so
um I would like to see more emphasis
placed on targeting individuals within
households and and therefore on more
individual payments and of course the
non-means tested benefits we've got are
largely individual rather than family
based now so I think those are two
things that we might look at in terms of
more broadly targeting need better than
we do at the moment I mean there are
lots of other things you could say
particularly in terms of the amounts of
benefit and the essentials guarantee
that was talked about in the previous
session thank you Richard thank you Chad
I think I'd I'd
um as you can imagine probably argue
that you know household support fund
works really well I think local
authorities would welcome an expansion
of that could offer an expansion of that
um the problem in the past has been that
uh the department has confirmed
household support funds with very little
time for local authorities to be able to
deliver them and with more time and
planning local authorities will be able
to deliver much better more targeted
schemes that deal with what their local
areas require
um certainly for our setup in
leicestershire the last round of
household support fund over spent by a
quarter of a million and the current
scheme has spent a quarter of a million
within the first month of opening so
demand is significantly higher than it's
ever been and I think that is just going
to to continue at the moment so we
definitely think there is scope for an
expansion in in schemes like that that
are very locally targeted
thank you thank you chair thank you
Nigel Mills
well we're on the household support from
that
I just said something Keen to explore
how far we could have gone I mean if
we'd rung you up and said
uh
uh you know rather than giving every
household on benefits
650 credit we'd like to give you the
equivalent amount of money for
leicestershire
bear in mind that probably every
household on benefits was going to need
some of that money to be able to pay a
1200 pound increase in their energy bill
I mean you'd have just drowned wouldn't
you trying to somehow get money to
you know thousands and thousands of
households in leicestershire quite
quickly with little notice in a crisis
but that's just not a realistic policy
option is it I think I think you're
right in that that element wouldn't be
realistic and you'd be looking at a
different approach rather than that kind
of blanket approach that that was Gone
with so what you would have seen is
um more fluctuations in the value of
Grant offered and things like that so
households would have got an appropriate
amount offered to them depending on the
number of dependent children in the
household or something like that so it
would have been a different scheme I
think if household support fund had done
it would it have reached the same number
of people not in the time scales with
which local authorities were given the
money and the guidance by DWP do I think
local government has the mechanics to be
able to offer that I think yes with the
right amount of planning it could do but
it would have been a different scheme I
think it's fair to say albeit I think
we'd argue one with more Nuance that was
better tailored
could I just add to that I mean I I I
absolutely take your point and and have
said that I think
um local
um or locally guided
um welfare uh um what was the local
welfare what is the local welfare
assistance scheme I.E one-off payments
in emergencies is important however it's
discretionary
it's cash limited it's often vouchers
rather than money and it's not as of
right so I think we have to bear all
those things in mind also it's not often
very much you didn't actually get very
much money I take your point that you
could have got 650 pounds
um but not to to those kinds of numbers
so
um I do think and the advice approach
which I think Richard was talking about
the integrated approach of ensuring that
you add advice into the package and not
just not just money is very important
which always means that you do have to
have the support of local advice
agencies as well as National benefit
schemes clearly
um but I just don't think that I think
there's a limit to how far we can go
down down that road can I just build on
that actually to do with advice and
knowledge
um I think I completely agree with ram
on that um the government's own
messaging around uh you know
kind of bills and energy bills have
involved a company called uswitch which
is quite a nice Innovative little
platform
um quite basically putting into the
hands of consumers really good choice
about how easy it is to switch between
different providers and how it is also
um some quite nice little tools online
as well to really tailor those
suggestions and definitely utilizing
um you know people's own wits and
knowledge about their own households is
really quite important but also speaking
quite extensively for the private sector
who you know Believe It or Not don't
want to have their customers freezing or
starving and are happy to work very
closely with the government on having
solutions to this crisis so
um I think it was the late Department
base that spoke to you switch but
definitely I would definitely recommend
um to the government definitely engaging
much more with the private sector on
this because they as I said they they
are still quite concerned about the
manner in which a lot of the the
households around the country in the
communities are suffering during this
quite terrible crisis
I'm just bikinis to pick back up on
Richard's point because I don't know how
many
households in leicestershire qualified
for the cost of an impairment it will be
tens and tens of thousands and probably
be in the hundreds of thousands
I mean it just wouldn't have been
realistic to ask every Council would it
design a scheme have different criteria
get people to apply and get that money
out in what was pretty fast-moving
crisis I mean the energy crisis what
started thus bring and we were trying to
get money out to people to pay the bills
over the winter I mean it would have
taken you longer than that to get enough
people to process all the applications
let alone
it doesn't strike me we could use the
household support fund as a way of
responding to a crisis where we wanted
to get significant amounts of money to
millions and millions of households is
it no I suppose if the objective is to
get money out to a large number of
households as quickly as possible then
no that wouldn't be the scheme you would
use and I suppose it depends upon what
you're setting out as The Guiding
principles what you want to achieve what
we believe we've got is a scheme that's
tailored but I think it's absolutely
right as you've said it's very if what
you value above everything else is
getting a set amount of money into
someone's bank account as fast as
possible that's a very different
approach to I think what the household
support fund offers I think going
forwards now we're in a
I think arguably more stable position
with the ability to to plan or accept it
um I think it offers a really good model
going forwards
did I just say I think I mean obviously
we need both we need the money in
people's accounts as of right we need a
sensitive emergency system
um so we we clearly need both one of the
things that your your question implied
was that it's just Council people who
are actually administering this I don't
think that's always the case and
certainly in Oxfordshire it was
delegated to the district councils and
then they delegated on to the advice
sector to give out some of the money
particularly in terms of nominating for
food and fuel vouchers and the problem
about that is that you tend to turn your
advice sector into people who have to
decide who's deserving of help and who
isn't and actually that isn't a role
that they welcome in my experience
um so I think that's one of the things
that we should also have to that we
should also think about as well clearly
you need advice as well as as the
financial supporters as as we've said
um but I think it it it's it's difficult
for a bisect for the advice sector to
have that role in addition
thank you
the I mean Lester did you use your
existing local welfare assistance
assistant scheme
to put the household support fund
through or was it really a new setup we
sensed it as a new scheme
okay thank you
um
Neil Coyle
thanks yeah um I I think you've heard
the earlier panels discussion of whether
we need a more supportive core benefit
system or a Top-Up system in crisis and
you've already touched on on part of
these questions uh main issue but what
are your organizations views on on the
preferability of re-uplifting Universal
Credit or continuing the cost of living
payments approach
and I've just asked on that
um I mean given the fact that the
one-off payments work as we heard
earlier very much you know gratefully
received and did actually make an impact
the uplift would be useful of course it
would
um and I think it is just a matter of
fact that more money people's pockets
means they whether the crisis better so
I think uh as an Institute I think that
is kind of where we would be basing I
mean our house view is a negative income
tax and that's something I can expand on
in Greater detail later on if you if you
wish but yes we'll come to that
fantastic yes um but but given the two
between you know one-off payments are
quite distant in between
um and a general uh uptake and flow of
money coming to people's pockets over
the long run I think that does make much
more sense and um actually if I may say
I don't think the uplift was enough
can I just add to that um
I need to be really clear
that we mean because the uplift was only
to the standard allowance of Universal
Credit and working tax credit and people
forget about the working tax credit it
was actually for one of the Legacy
benefits as well but it was only to the
standard allowance of Universal Credit
or the basic rate of working tax credits
so actually if what you mean is an
increase in benefit rates
um uh then I would definitely agree with
that as did the previous panel I think
um and I would agree with that for the
non-means tested benefits as as well as
the means tested
one-off payments uh were appreciated by
some people because they were flexible
and because
um they they came all at once and you
could pay off a particular I mean I know
somebody who used it to buy a cooker
because their cooker had just broken
down for example
um but there should be a system that
copes with that and there should be a
system which is generous enough so that
people can save up for that kind of
emergency anyway
your early criticism of complexifying
the system would also
allow for the introductive something
like the social fund to cover the
emergency cooker replacement or
alternative issues as well as a more
generous call system yeah and I mean the
local welfare assistance was meant to be
a placement for parts of the
discretionary social fund although it's
a bit different because local
authorities don't have the as I
understand it don't have the capacity to
administer loans so the loans element of
the discretionary social fund got got
dropped by most councils doing local
welfare assistance I think
um but yes absolutely there has to be a
backup emergency benefit payment system
but that the most important thing is
getting the the basic structure of the
benefit system right and its amount
adequate and one of the other things we
haven't talked about is how you operate
benefits it was mentioned briefly in the
previous panel and you might have a
system of operating benefits which would
use either reference budgets or the
costs of living for low-income
households because we know they have
um they spend a larger proportion of
their budget on these Essentials which
have actually been going up enormously
and so on so there are different methods
of upgrading benefits and increasing
benefits which might also be held for
just a quick follow-up on on this issue
of the uplift obviously the government
ignored the campaign to try and retain
that uplift and I just wonder if you sit
the NHL poverty statistics this week
suggest I think it was a 600 000
increase in children in poverty uh
including I think seven in ten children
working parents living in poverty I I
just when you looked at their stats and
considered the impact of the the
reduction of Universal Credit in the
cost of living crisis and what your
views are
looking at the statistics it was quite
clear that
um The Uplift wasn't in line with
inflation and you know it's very
concerning to see these
um large increases in child poverty
especially child poverty but also
poverty across the board
um however we I mean you know we're a
free market think tank so we do we do
take into consideration the fact that
money is very very tight at the moment
especially in the treasury there's a lot
of borrowing taxes at an all-time high
so we there is some sympathy from our
perspective about the
not being so happy to uplift the the
benefits even more but
um you know it's it's a difficult it's a
very very difficult argument to have
when there is you know that very
long-term future view of the debt is
essentially unsustainable and also um
there's large amounts of poverty that
debate is I think somewhat out of the
reach of an economic research think tank
but at the same time it's in my personal
view it is a case that I think the
government probably should have put some
more money aside to uplift those
benefits across the board
okay thank you very much indeed maybe
Abrahams
very appreciable yes to Maxwell's point
but to Richard so I agree that my
experience with the household support
fund has been very it's been successful
I think it does it enables the targeting
of the vulnerable households in in a
really good way but if we were going to
uplift the benefits I think the 20 20
pound was it costs about 9 billion quid
in a year and it's perhaps has come down
with reduced payments but
is it your experience of dealing with
vulnerable households that we could
uplift the benefits payments add the 20
quid back and then we would still need
to be putting money into a vulnerable
support scheme because that is certainly
my experience because so we're basically
so I think the household support fund is
in at least a billion if not a billion
and a half so are we rolling we're
basically ending up at 10 and a half
billion which does become quite it
becomes quite unaffordable are you set
so I think sorry I was being very offly
but are you saying that you wouldn't
want to see the loss of the vulnerable
support in any circumstances
think we would leave I think local
authorities would believe that that the
loss of the ability to locally target
support to those in need and
particularly short-term support and
emergency crisis type support would be
the detriment of our communities and so
I think the idea of sort of saying we
wouldn't need something like the
households in a ton of across the living
crisis if benefits had been raised I
don't think that that would those two
would kind of have an equivalence
Maxwell you had a comment given or
across the affordability issue for the
treasury yes
um again as I said earlier it is a big
concern in terms of this but I think if
you are to look at the way in which the
money flows from this kind of um
from these payments down with the
economy they are in many ways
recirculated
um so there are there is some down the
line gains that treasury can reclaim
through additional spending through
indirect taxation for example so it's
not
completely unaffordable but if I were a
special advisor I would definitely say
that we do need to have a proper look at
the targeting of this and definitely
limit how much we are spending
could I just say I would agree
absolutely that we need an increase in
benefits but also a backstop in terms of
an emergency stop
very much I think probably
um you're not going to have much more to
to say on this um so given particularly
from what you have said about the the
need for a
stroll design uh redesign rather of the
of the system and and so on and the
points you made about increasing some
Simplicity reducing complexity ensuring
fairness across the plethora of
different uh support payments there is
in an emergency system what would you do
start with Fran and if there are any
when you say an emergency system you
mean a crisis for the country or people
themselves so
it's cost of living payment was
introduced in in a crisis situation as
an emergency so recognizing that needs
to be available for us and we've talked
about the local welfare assistance
scheme as as an example what what would
you want to see well if you were in
charge what would you have done last
autumn
um I think the um uh increase in in
benefits would have to be a first one I
mean I think it depends what your aim is
because clearly
um the government wanted to help all
households in some ways and as I
understand it that isn't the kind of
help we're talking about today so
um the um you know the amount that was
taken off everybody's fuel bills for
example was obviously part of the
addressing of the crisis but I don't
think it's something we're looking at
today we're only looking at the cost of
living payments and as as I understand
it those are the means tested ones and
the passported means tested ones and the
disability payment and the pensioner
payment and I've been concentrating
mostly on the the means tested payments
so that's the area I would look at and
clearly you want to do something which
is
um is uh quick and uh is effective and
effective has lots of different meanings
um and can help those people people that
need it I mean I would have tried to do
an increase in in benefits as a as a as
an emergency
payment but I can quite see that
um the ad hoc payment system that the
government has got appears to be able to
be quicker
um so I and and one thing which we
haven't emphasized I think is that
unlike the uplift the one-off payment
does go to people on all the Legacy
benefits as well
um uh at the cost of living payments so
I think we need to stress that it should
be uh people on Legacy benefits as well
as Universal Credit who have an increase
in uh doesn't seem to be a design issue
then doesn't it
in sort of how the payments are process
if we wanted to do anything a bit more
yes I think part of the problem is that
the um the the government has invested
in I.T particularly for Universal Credit
but has somewhat neglected the I.T for
the Legacy benefit systems because
they're going to be phased out so that
may be part of the issue that they're
they're talking about okay thank you
would you like to add anything to that
yeah I'm happy to add to that I think
very quickly yeah very quickly um the I
think the university system I'm very
thankful that we had it I don't think
the Legacy benefit system would have
been able to put up with the pandemic so
I think it would have actually collapsed
um it was a bit of a mess and then um
obviously with the cost of living
support it was able to basically
Channel those payments in very quickly
and would be no surprise to anyone on
the committee that we'd also have gone
for some indirect tax cuts to help
basically
cut down the actual cost of living on
the essentials on the you know getting
to work on paying your fuel Bill and a
lot of taxes on you know your energy
costs as well so no surprise there to
anyone but definitely that I think we
definitely from our analysis that would
definitely have helped quite a lot thank
you Richard do you want time to do
anything I'm not sure I've got a huge
amount to to add to this one really
thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much Steve
McCabe
thank you
um I think I want to put this mostly to
Fran Fran I just wondered if the
the
kind of current sort of cost of living
support payments I'm not that effective
is there a better model that you would
recommend
probably already answered that in that I
think we should be
um
be reversing some of the cuts that we've
had in the benefit system we should have
more generous
benefits and we should have an emergency
payment system to cope with emergency
well that was it there isn't anything
felt totally different than you want to
I mean I think something like the
difference in in methods of upgrading I
mean
um that that either you establish a
reference budget uh which is the kind of
thing that the essentials guarantee has
done
um uh or you actually look at up rating
itself in terms of increases with the
um costs of living that are facing
low-income households rather than
necessarily just the average CPI those
kinds of things would would also be
useful and there are lots of ways in
which I would like to reform the benefit
System including the algorithm for the
Universal Credit calculation which is
very rigid I think and holds us back in
various different policy directions
and if I wanted to look at other
countries where would you tell me to
look yeah there are some some examples
of emerging you know what's happened in
the cost of living crisis for from
different countries and the oecd has
looked at this for working age people
and and I've also got information about
different countries from from other
sources too it's very mixed picture the
elements are quite similar for from with
the cost of living package that we've
done in the UK so for example Austria
has given one off cost of living
payments like we have but the
particularly striking thing I think is
the number of countries who've given
more to children in this cost of living
crisis so for example Finland has
increased benefits for under 18s by 10
Canada has given extra for Working
Families Estonia and Austria actually
gave more for larger families than they
did for smaller families Ireland I think
is double child benefit the Netherlands
has given extra cash benefits for
families so that's a really
um I think that's a really
um clear path that we didn't take
Slovakia has indexed benefits with the
living costs for low-income households
Belgium has given an increase on top of
indexation for the next four years uh
czechia and Sweden have given increases
in help with housing costs Slovakia has
given increased given increased help to
carers sorry I'm reading these because I
can't remember them all off the top of
my head Germany has given a heating cost
allowance and then there are other
things which are not to do with the
benefit system which we're talking about
benefits particularly today but Ireland
has given public transport subsidies
which in fact we have as well because we
gave the two pounds bus ticket France as
you know probably has given government
discounts on certain Goods certain basic
Goods they've also given protection from
disconnection in certain months
Luxembourg is an increase in minimum
wage and increasing tax-free limits so
there's lots of different lots of stuff
but the the child issues
I don't know if you have the earlier
panel but I was asking about the
150 pounds disability cost of living
allowance and I was struck when I was
looking at changes to the Warren homes
discount which is actually worth about
150 pounds as well and it's according to
the house of Coleman's Library
um about 300 000 households with uh
people in receipt of a disability
benefit are about to lose the worms
homes discount which as I say is what
about 150 pounds because of the changes
uh well basically because those benefits
have been withdrawn from the eligibility
criteria is that
first um I was quite baffled by this
um given by the fact that you know
people with disabilities do use
um quite a lot of energy more than the
um average person
um so it just yeah I was a little I was
quite confused when the when the
government did this
um well put it into place basically so I
would suggest reversing that and because
it's it seems a bit mean and I don't
like that
I mean I don't have anything to add to
that it's not an area of expertise for
me I don't really have anything to add
to that um or or what the person from
mencap said earlier
thank you thank you very much indeed and
just Fran you mentioned Slovakia they
used did you say that they were
operating benefits in line with the
costs for low-income households was was
that a sort of a separate index because
I understand it yeah okay that's
interesting yeah
um
Maxwell um can you explain the logic of
your suggestion uh that the cost of
living payment be made to any household
without a higher level taxpayer rather
than the more focused approach that has
been adopted so so house view has been
negative income tax and that's a
fundamental shift to
um negative income tax across the entire
system so it doesn't just cover the
one-off payments
um the reason I'll quickly you know kind
of talk a little bit about what the
differences are between Ubi which has
been obviously in the news quite a lot
recently negative income tax and the
current system so I'll start with the
Ubi Ubi is basically saying um here's
100 quid you give me 50 Quid later right
so it's basically a a soft like a hard
floor on income on households throughout
the country no matter you know who is
eligible there's no means testing
involved
um that has been obviously discussed and
it's going to be trialled in a couple of
areas in the country over the next few
months and I've seen there's quite a lot
of outrage about it right right exactly
quite a lot of outrage negative income
tax on the other side is a completely
Dynamic model so it's essentially saying
um I mean you make how do you pay
negative tax you don't
um when you have a baseline of zero
pounds income you receive the maximum
allotted now this has been tried in
three different places in the US to some
success there's some concern essentially
I believe from the conservative Ventures
that it would kind of reduce the amount
reduce the incentive to go to work the
actual figures that we find when these
experiments were run is that this
actually isn't the case
um the reason why we like it is because
of the um the cliff edges that
essentially just eliminates it's a
completely tapered rate so essentially
there is no Cliff Edge anywhere on the
system and by the time you reach the
break-even point you um either gain
nothing from the state and pay nothing
to the state so
um essentially it reduces the complete
complexity even though it's a much more
simple model with Universal Credit at
the moment it reduces the complexity
completely and is much more efficient so
let's say
um I know recent figures came out that
about 5 million people are out of work
if they were to dip their toe into the
water they are quite concerned that they
would immediately lose you know many of
the uh benefits and payments that they
receive from DWP and that's actually
quite a large disincentive to return to
work and it's something that obviously
the economy is feeling at the moment
with a negative income tax this changes
completely
um so even if you enter a low low wage
work and the household income is still
low you still receive some benefits but
not as much as those who aren't in work
so it's a gradual encouragement up to
moving up the kind of career ladder and
as we've seen with the cliff edges as I
said earlier Miss Linden um essentially
it as as we saw with the um the child
care reforms it's essentially telling
people to not go for a pay rise or not
progress in their career because they
could actually lose more money than if
they just chose not to take it I'd say
that's really bad for the economy and
that's why we go for the negative income
tax which is as I said a completely
Dynamic model
so in it other than the Prejudice that
idlers might choose to do nothing what
do you anticipate are going to be the
Principal obstacles to implementing such
a magnificent system
certainly a difficult system and one
thing that we've had a look at is kind
of the computational power to process
the algorithms to deliver this system it
would be quite a
quite a change from the way in which any
other country does it
um as I'm sure we're all aware but um
so the computational power is the big
first one
um the government's recent AI strategy
and I'm sure that's something that we
weren't expecting to talk about here but
the AI strategy essentially is going to
increase the computational power of the
government and something we really
recommend and I know
um Mel stride is definitely a big fan of
this is increasing the tech take up
within the department to essentially
automate the state and make things much
more smooth and dynamic and working all
the time with a few troubleshoots the
other issue is of course the cost
so um R so so we published something
quite recently with nickel Woodruff and
the policy engine who essentially found
that if one were to abolish the personal
allowance and replace it with kind of a
33 pounds a week
uplift from the current benefit system
through a national negative income tax
you can actually reduce the poverty rate
across the country overall by 35 percent
there's quite a large data set he used
so what we we run the numbers and
although there's some expense to start
off with and to change things over be a
few billion you would see a long run
um a long run benefit to everyone in the
country how many is a few billion a few
billion uh we don't have access to all
the data mainly because the DWP haven't
released all the figures yet
a ballpark ballpark
out
35 billion that's more than a few
all relative yeah
it's a couple of things
um well I was wasn't aware well I was
aware we were going to discuss negative
income tax but I wasn't aware this is
what this session was about but because
we have raised negative income tax there
are a few questions such as what's the
unit so
um would this be jointly means tested
for everybody uh what about individual
taxation uh what happens to that what
about individually based benefits do
they all get abolished and merged into
negative income tax which is the only
system we'll have how often are people
means tested with the adjustment made to
their income can it be completely
automated or not there are all sorts of
questions about negative income tax
which were we here to talk about that I
would very much like to discuss
I think you've given us a clue
so the the point about individual
taxation with that be lost under your
proposal
um not entirely no
um I think another issue with our
current taxation system is coming back
to it again is the cliff Edge problem
and um the benefits of the negative
income taxes it's actually it is an
incentive to work because the uh
the way in which the graphs that we drew
are quite that's a completely linear
graph um if you take a standard angle on
the graph where the negative income tax
Rises it's about 45 degrees and that's
kind of it's it's much more shallow than
our current system which is um well see
a higher degree so
generally it would lower taxes which is
better for the economy in our opinion
but it would also provide a much more
seamless means of support somewhat in
line with the one-off payments it gives
much more
um gives much more flexibility to
families receiving the tax receipt
receiving the negative income tax
another interesting thing is what
happens about conditionality
um because clearly the current
government and previous governments
before it had been quite um interested
in conditionality and I'm not going to
comment on it but I just wonder whether
like with a universal basic income the
negative income tax also does away with
conditionality
um I might get to come back on that
that's okay um there will be some
conditionality um and I would also like
to to comment that it wouldn't it would
have to be
um added to by disability benefit and
kind of other areas where you know
people have a greater expense on their
households including with children so
um it would require it's it's not just a
kind of a simple model that Milton
Friedman first put out when he was
suggesting it back in the 70s but it
would require a little bit more
tailoring which I'm sure DWP are most
capable of you you
um referenced a number of studies where
counter-intuitively it hadn't led to
people shirking because they had an
income
have we you know is there any
detail on
uh the analysis of why that may not have
been the case
um
I can send the studies to the committee
afterwards if that they would like for a
little bit more further reading it's
quite there's a lot of numbers and
models and details which I don't think
would fit Hansard and would certainly um
be a little bit easier on the ice just
to read through so I'm very happy to
write into the committee later with with
those studies I'd be most grateful we'll
study them with great interest
um thank you very much indeed that
concludes the questions we wanted to put
to you and very grateful to all of you
for being willing to give evidence to us
this morning and for the very helpful
information you provided thank you very
much that concludes our meeting order